hey guys you know the role of a father
is extremely important more than most
men will ever realize Unfortunately they
only realize it when it is too late and
you can never go back you can never make
it right again we have a fatherless
problem in the world today and even when
fathers are at home a lot of them are
not really
present are you according to fod . kids
who grow up with a present engaged dad
are less likely to drop out of school or
wind up in
jail compared to children with absent
fathers and no other male caretakers or
Role Models when children have close
relationships with Father
figures they tend to avoid highrisk
behaviors and they're less likely to
have sex at a young age they're more
likely to have high-paying jobs and
healthy stable relationships when they
grow up you see the world is downplaying
the role of a father but the role of a
father is extremely important listen to
the rest of this they also tend to have
higher IQ test scores by the age of
three and endure fewer psychological
problems throughout their lives when
dads take the role of a father seriously
alt together these benefits of having an
Engaged dad are called the father
effect now you might not have had a
great father you know an
example but that is no excuse because as
with everything in life you can always
learn and improve yourself and there are
many things that we can talk about but I
want to focus in on five extremely
important things that can help you to be
a better father these are things that I
experienced with my dad a dad who lived
the way he
preached he's not here anymore he passed
away but all those things he taught me
changed my life forever let's start with
the first
thing the first thing is follow God's
word because that actually takes
everything into account when you want to
be a good father even the small things
for example the Bible says that you have
to be a man of your word that means
including when you make promises to your
children you should keep them that's
what my dad did James
5:12 but above all my brothers do not
swear either by heaven or by Earth or by
any other oath but let your yes be yes
and your no be no so that you may not
not fall under
condemnation the biggest thing your
child needs from you is love but also
trust trust if you don't keep your
promises if your yes is not yes and your
no is not no what do you think is going
to happen they're not going to trust you
right and that's just one thing in the
word of God follow God's word and see
how it will improve you to become a
better father here's another example
Proverbs 20:7 says the righteous who
walks in his Integrity blessed are his
children after him my dad lived
according to God's word and that
automatically made him a man of
integrity because he followed God's word
and me being young all those years
growing up I saw how my dad lived with
Integrity that he was a doer of the word
and not just a hearer and and today I am
blessed after him because I saw all his
decisions experiences and actions how he
walked in integrity and I will never
forget it now if you don't know God's
word then it is time to learn it Psalm
119 ver 105 says your word is a lamp to
my feet and a light to my
path the world is full of Darkness as
your children will also experience
but if you stay there in the darkness
trying to lead them you will stumble
you'll be lost and you will also cause
them to be lost and that is where you
will stay in darkness forever you need
God's word to be a lamp for your feet on
this Earthly temporary Journey so that
you can see the truth for yourself and
walk towards the destiny the purpose
that God has for you if you follow God
and he worth word God will bless you
equip you with everything you need to
take on every obstacle that this life
throws at you and you know sometimes it
is not easy to raise children but God
will help you with that as well 2
Timothy 3:16 Says all scripture is
breathed out by God and profitable for
teaching for reproof for correction and
for training in righteousness that the
man of God may be complete equipped for
every good
work discipline in
love all of us we are born as human
beings with have a sinful nature your
kids you never have to tell them to be
naughty they just are
why because of the sinful nature in us
that we are born with David said in
Psalm
51:5 behold I was brought forth in an
equity and in sin that my mother
conceive me now when we become reborn
Christians we receive a new spiritual
nature the Holy Spirit right so we have
that nature we also still have that old
sinful flesh and when we act through the
spirit we will not sin this new nature
helps us to overcome sin but when we
don't act through the spirit when we act
through the flesh we will sin we will
fall and so not only not only do we
receive the new spiritual nature we also
become children of God he adopts us
after he declared us as righteous but
that doesn't mean that when we sin he
will just think okay that's fine and
just leave it he disciplines us as a
good father because he loves us
Revelation 3:1 19 says Those whom I love
I reprove and discipline so be zealous
and
repent and in the same way if you truly
love your children you will also
discipline them if they are naughty or
do evil because if you don't you're
basically teaching them that they can do
evil sinful things with no consequences
so it's fine go ahead Proverbs 22:15
says Folly is bound up in the heart of a
child but the rod of discipline drives
it far from him so if you don't
discipline them they will think they can
always get what they want when they want
they don't care who they hurt they can
just do whatever and they will get their
desires no one stops me there's no
consequences so why not and then they
become extremely selfish and that's how
they grow up and that's how they become
these mature men and women walking
around who are extremely selfish and
just care about themselves so if you
don't care if you don't truly love your
kids and you don't discipline them then
this is what might happen to them so if
you love them and truly care about them
you will discipline them Proverbs 13:4
says whoever spares the rod hates his
son but he who loves him is diligent to
discipline him so think about it this
way if you don't discipline them you
actually nurture that sinful fleshly
nature of them even more and more so
they grow up they don't really care that
much about right and wrong anymore
they're a bad husband a bad father they
do sleep around they do whatever they
want at work they steal they bribe they
do whatever they want because that's how
you taught them it's okay there's no
consequences Proverbs 29: 17 says
discipline your son and he will give you
rest he will give the light to your
heart and Proverbs 22:6 says train up a
child in the way he should go
even when he is old he will not depart
from it now this does not mean that you
should be harsh with them or provoke
them to anger or beat them blue and
purple that is not what God's word says
but depending on their
personality you need to discipline them
with wisdom and love Ephesians 6:4 says
fathers do not provoke your children to
anger but bring them up in dead
discipline and instruction of the
Lord you know I was always busy and
naughty so so my dad he would keep his
word he would give me three warnings but
if I didn't listen he said he is going
to Spang me after the third time and he
always did that gave me security uh a
kind of structure to know there's always
consequences and also to know that my
dad will keep his word
and afterward you know after I cried he
spanked me he would explain to me
exactly again to make sure that I know
why he gave me a spanking what I did was
wrong and I needed to
apologize and then I did that he hugged
me he told me he loves me the
relationship is restored again father
son and then I continued but I learned
my lesson those three warnings gave me
structure security there a lot of people
who scream at their kids and they
threaten them Seven 8 nine 10 times if
you do this again I'm going to do this
and that and you don't do that and so
there's no structure sometimes you say
it three times sometimes 15 so that
means you don't keep your word if you
say to your child if you do this again I
am going to discipline you then you need
to keep your word and do it they need
that structure to know that when you say
something as their parent that you will
do what you said you will do there's a
difference between being a friend to
your child which you also need to be and
then that Authority where they learn
respect for you Hebrews 12:11 says for
the moment all discipline seems painful
rather than pleasant but later it yields
the peaceful fruit of righteousness to
those who have been trained by it you
know some parents are against
disciplining their kids and you can just
see how those kids they have no respect
for their parents but they then scream
at their kids scream and loud you know
psychological abuse is a lot
worse Colossians 3:21 says fathers do
not provoke your children lest they
become
discouraged so discipline your children
in love if they did something bad after
you warn them a few times let's say the
third time you discipline them and just
don't leave it there just don't
discipline them and walk away no talk to
them have a conversation make sure they
understand why you discipline them and
tell them to apologize and then give
them a hug give them a kiss restore that
relationship and then you continue you
need to do that in the same way that God
is now your father you are his child and
so when you go and you do something bad
you come back and you say you're sorry
he forgives you and you
continue say
sorry apologize ask forgiveness it's not
just your kids who need to apologize and
ask you for forgiveness when they do
something wrong you need to set the
example there's no such thing as a
perfect father we all know that you will
make mistakes and then they look at you
your kids they look at how you act so
you can't expect them to say sorry if
you don't do it so if you did something
wrong own that mistake mistake apologize
ask them to forgive you never just
ignore it because if you do your kids
will do the same James 5:16 confess your
sins to one another and pray for one
another that you may be healed you know
my dad would always do this and for a
lot of men this might be difficult
because of Pride they wrongly think that
if they do this if they apologize to
their kids then they would think less of
them and that's because of Pride the
sinful flesh is actually the opposite
for example my dad would come if he and
my mom had wordss for example in the
kitchen and we were there we saw this
conversation he would come back later
and he would apologize to her and also
to us he would say something like you
know even if what I said was right the
way I spoke to your mother was not right
please forgive me and then we would and
that made me respect him so so much more
and that
example helps even me today in my
marriage and with all other
relationships to own my mistakes to say
I am sorry when I'm wrong it's easy not
to do it to just ignore it right that's
easy because it's part of the sinful
flesh but it's through the spirit that
you will go and make things right
between you and your family own your
mistakes set that example and your kids
will follow there will be this openness
this beautiful love where people are
humble and um there's no place for sin
or the devil to creep in and break up
that family because of
Pride put your family
first not yourself or other things put
them first it's one of the reasons I
loved my dad so much you know he would
he would give his lost money or take off
his his clothes just so that we can go
and study and get degrees he did
everything for us and he didn't even
think about it twice there were so many
things that he sacrificed from his own
life that now that he passed away I'm
starting to remember
things and I appreciate it so much
Philippians 2:3 says do nothing from
selfish ambition or conceit but in
humility count others more significant
than yourselves Let each of you look not
only to his own interests but also to
the interests of others pride and
selfishness can always come between you
and your kids it will prevent you from
having a good relationship for example
Pride stops you from asking
forgiveness selfishness prevents you
from putting your children up as one of
the highest priorities in your life and
ignorance stops you from spending enough
quality time with them because you think
they need your money
more you know as a reborn Christian you
have the Holy Spirit in you which means
loving them your family is not just when
you want to it's an act of your will
it's agape love unconditional love there
t love as well and F which means there's
friendship love and family love right OS
love is sexual love and that comes only
together with your wife right but all
the others is with you and your kids and
you need to do that always even when you
see your children needs to spend time
with you even when you're tired and
don't feel like it there are moments in
your life when you need to sacrifice
your own feelings and give them what
they need and the moment you put on that
switch when you act through the spirit
you will suddenly see that your your
whole soul your emotions your intellect
your own will just comes together and
now now you want to spend time with them
you know my dad did not always have a
lot of money but he tried his best even
though he was very busy to always take
time and spend time with us as his kids
we are five kids five very different
personalities and he tried to connect
with each one of us on our level with
our different personality your children
should not learn to become a great man
or woman from school or from their
friends they learn it from you their
identity they get that from you
money it's going to make things worse
they need you time with you and if you
don't spend time with them how are you
going to know what they truly need and
how to spend time with them specifically
and how are you going to put them first
in your life
truly let me ask you a few questions do
you even know the favorite colors of of
your
kids what are their favorite hobbies
what do they like what don't they like
and do they know those things of you do
they know
you make time for your kids time passes
so quick and one of these days they'll
be mature and then when you look back in
your
life those thoughts would come and you
would think man I should have spent more
time with them I should have gone more
fishing I should have done this more I
should have done that more well now you
still have time you can't go back right
now into the past but you have time to
do things right now so act now and don't
wait for regret let's move on to the
next
one number five love
them and make sure that they know you
love them you know my my dad wasn't a
perfect father because there's no such
thing as we said at the beginning of
this video but he was near because he
lived the way he preached when he made
mistakes he would come back ask
forgiveness and make it right and he
would always make sure that we know that
he loved
us do your kids know that you love them
they're not going to know it through you
buying them gifts or taking them fishing
or doing other things for them they
might even get too spoiled and not
appreciate things enough if you always
just give them stuff you need to tell
them you love them from your lips they
need to hear it some parents might be a
little bit hesitant or afraid you know
if they are going to be too strict or or
not strict but tell them don't do this
don't do that then they might think you
don't love them anymore no you love them
if you discipline them you can tell them
the truth of certain things when they go
off the right path you know they make
their own decisions especially when they
grow up and then you leave them but you
still tell them this is right this is
wrong with love and when you tell them
that they should never feel that you
don't love them anymore that you don't
care about them God our Father is a good
example he loves us and we know it but
he doesn't love our sin Romans 5:8 says
but God shows his love for us and that
while we were still
sinners Christ died for
us love them and keep on praying for
them always let them know that you're
praying for them as well you know my
story was like the story of the prodical
son I knew my parents loved me and I
also knew that they were praying for me
I went away but you know God was working
in me and I think it's because of those
prayers and I came back so let them know
that you pray for them do not quarrel
unnecessarily with your kids always tell
them oh don't do this don't do this
don't do this show them love as well
there needs to be a balance tell them
the truth in love but then continue the
relationship with them as well so that
they will know that you love them God
gave them free will to make their own
decisions so let them make their own
decisions as God L you make your own
decisions but we know what God's word
says we know what he wants from us and
it's the same thing with you and your
kids you tell them this is right this is
wrong but then when they get that
certain age you kind of have to let them
go when they leave the net
but never stop to be a good example and
always pray for them 1 Timothy 2:8 says
I desire then that in every place the
men should pray lifting holy hands
without anger or
quarreling 1 Thessalonians 5:17 says
pray without seizing and James 5:16 says
the prayer of a righteous person has
great power as it is working
now remember there is no such thing as a
perfect father only God the father he is
a perfect father and we can try our best
to follow his example now go and be a
great father and always remember that
life is short so don't waste yours
because what will your kids think of you
when you're not here
anymore cheers
guys